so it's fall it's still pilot season so
we have some new shows some good some
bad some they're already canceled but
sometimes one comes along and it's
awesome The Walking Dead alright so if
you guys remember at Comic Con some of
the Walking Dead was screened and
everyone loved it got great reviews so I
personally was looking forward to it and
of course it premieres of all nights on
Halloween and if you didn't get many
people trick-or-treating at your house
The Walking Dead is probably why are so
as you guys probably should know by now
I'm a huge zombie movie fan and I loved
The Walking Dead I mean The Walking Dead
has everything you love about a zombie
movie but it actually I mean it has
heart too I don't care if this sounded
gay it has heart so the story ultimately
revolves around one guy who wakes up in
a hospital amidst the zombie apocalypse
sounds a little familiar doesn't it so
he gets outside to find out there are
dead and there are Walking Dead and so
he's convinced his family's alive he's
trying to get to them now so that one
dude from snatches in the movie him and
his son and it's really something of a
show that gets you to care about a
supporting character when he's only in
the first episode for like half of it I
don't know you'll probably see him again
throughout the show but for now half of
one episode and you give a [ __ ] and yeah
the zombies in this movie are the you
know senior citizens with hip
replacement zombies they don't run but
as done right there actually menacing
like the scene at the end with the town
and all the zombies and closing in on it
dude that's intense
that's like a nightmare there's the
zombie dream and the zombie nightmare
that was the zombie nightmare I
personally was a little concerned
hearing that it was coming on AMC me not
that I have anything against AMC AMC is
just TV and I was thinking about great a
zombie movie that's edited but not so is
the case headshots blood and gorn zombie
tastic awesomeness that's what we want
and that's what we get it's really funny
because I DVR all these shows so I have
like a few shows to watch i watch The
Walking Dead first every show after that
I still had zombies on my mind
everything they did in these other shows
I was thinking to myself yeah they're
doing that because of the zombies the
show sticks with you this badass try to
tell me that heaven is not a real place
it is it's called your living room
watching AMC on Sunday nights I mean has
all the zombie excitement that you loved
about zombie movies and it has emotion
to it it's hard for a show to nail that
I just expected a zombie show I got a
lot more gotta say I was pleasantly
surprised so I don't know how the show
is going to go from now
I mean one episode in the rest of the
show could just suck horribly but the
pilot episode was really good so if
you're a zombie movie fan I'd like to
hope that you saw the first episode if
you haven't seen it catch up on it and
watch this show for sure if you're not a
zombie movie fan I actually think the
show might actually offer you things
that you'd like anyway so you should
probably check it out so The Walking
Dead has the potential to be great but I
mean as we've all learned there's a
difference between potential and reality
yeah
so my recommendation check it out and if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more